Let's look at an example where we have.
Actual elements. I'm going to pull up
the previous diagram so
Let's look at this from a different perspective.
Let's say, you know Universal set. We also had.
our Universal set has the letters a through I
a b c d e r n z a
D E. F G H are in B
and I is just out on so
if we take the complement of set a
we will discard a b c.
But d and e get to stay because what DNA
also exists in set B.
in addition to the letter i
because that's in the Universal set.
If we take the complement of set B.
So he has D E F G H. Yes, but D
and E are inside a so we get.
if sorry d
e
a b
c and the letter i
d e because well
the audience at a ABC and the letter
i
from the universal set
notice
Oh we have here.
How many elements do these have in common?
I mean if put differently what is intersection of
not a and not be
what it is intersection of these two sets.
so that would give us
d e
and I
in other words when we take the intersection
of the complements of A and B.
We will get the universal set. Excuse me,
the one element outside in the
Universal set.
Plus the elements that they have in common.
If we had taken the intersection of A and B.
We would have gotten.
D and E
only the elements they have in common.
But when you take the intersection of the complement of a and the
complement of B, you will get the elements that
they have in common Plus.
the element out in the Universal set
Now, let's go back up to what we had before.
and return to our table containing the
joint and
marginal frequencies
A and B together have five elements.
But when you take the intersection of complement of
a and complement of B, you will take the 5
that they haven't come in plus the 25 that live
outside.
I've set A and B the 25 5 plus
25 that gives us 30.
And that's how we get what we get over here.
Now we have a table containing.
The Joint frequencies and the marginal frequencies.
Well we are going to do next is turn
these frequencies into relative
frequencies.
When we do this, this will become analogous.
two probability
We can use relative frequency to get to probability. Once we
go from the frequency to relative frequency, then
we can talk about.
Conditional and Joint probabilities, so
that's what we will get next.